et cela est encore plus dangereux.
Ils deviennent facilement la proie des populistes pendant les élections
ou prennent même les armes.
Une « fake news » n'est pas mauvaise que pour la presse
mais est une menace pour la démocratie et la société.
Il y a quatre ans, des soldats anonymes
sont entrés dans la péninsule de Crimée,
et en même temps,
les médias russes étaient remplis de « fake news » sur l'Ukraine.
Alors, un groupe de journalistes, dont je fais partie,
a développé un site internet pour enquêter sur ces « fake news ».
Nous l'avons appelé StopFake.
L'idée était simple :
on prenait une nouvelle, et on la vérifiait avec des preuves tangibles,
comme des photos, des vidéos et d'autres preuves solides.
Si elle se révélait être fausse, on la mettait sur notre site.
Aujourd'hui, StopFake est un centre d'informations
qui analyse la propagande sous tous ses aspects.
Le site existe en 11 langues, nous avons des millions de visiteurs,
et nous avons montré à plus de 10 000 personnes
comment distinguer la vérité des mensonges.
Et nous avons formé des vérificateurs de faits partout dans le monde.
StopFake a découvert plus de 1 000 fausses nouvelles sur l'Ukraine.
Nous avons identifié 18 récits
créés à partir de « fake news »,
tels que « l'Ukraine est un État fasciste »,
« un État qui a fait faillite »,
« un État gouverné par une junte militaire
qui est arrivée au pouvoir par un coup d’État ».
Nous avons prouvé que
ce n'est pas du mauvais journalisme.
C'est un acte délibéré de désinformation.
Les « fake news » sont une arme puissante
dans le combat de l'information,
mais il y a quelque chose que nous pouvons faire pour les combattre.
Nous avons tous des smartphones.
Quand on voit quelque chose d'intéressant,
c'est souvent automatique :
on a juste à cliquer pour le diffuser.
Comment ne pas participer à la diffusion de « fake news » ?
En premier, si c'est trop dramatique, trop émouvant, trop accrocheur,
alors, c'est très probable que ce ne soit pas vrai.
La vérité est ennuyeuse, parfois.
(Rires)
Les manipulations sont toujours sexy.
Elles sont pensées pour vous attirer.
Faites vos propres recherches.
C'est le deuxième point, c'est très simple.
Regardez sur d'autres sites.
Vérifiez des sources alternatives.
Cherchez sur Google noms, adresses,
plaques d'immatriculation, experts et offres.
Ne croyez pas à tout, vérifiez !
C'est la seule façon d’arrêter cette culture des « fake news ».
Cette guerre d'information n'est pas seulement basée
sur les « fake news ».
Notre société dépend de la confiance :
la confiance en nos institutions,
en la science,
la confiance en nos leaders,
la confiance en la presse.
Et c'est à nous de trouver une façon de restaurer la confiance,
parce que les « fake news » la détruisent.
Donc demandez-vous :
en quoi avez-vous perdu la foi ?
Qu'est-ce qui a détruit votre confiance ?
Et qu'est-ce que vous allez faire pour la restaurer ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)